so the other day
one of the guys from my community posted
this video can i add this to stream yeah
uh from coach redpo gonzalez uh title is
leave now while you can i'm not to play
it you guys can go watch it
it's pretty bleak
there's some conversation around it and
um basically the tldr version of it was
get the hell out things are going to go
downhill fast and if you're not out by i
think you said the spring
you're going to be all wrapped up in a
war with china
i don't think
north america is going to go anywhere
near war with china personally
um
they're going to lose
it's just a matter of fact man you know
you take a look at the numbers they're
they're not going to pick a fight with
china um if china wants taiwan i think
the west is going to let them have it
you know if i'm being honest
i like gonzalo and we've talked a few
times
online and even offline in the last
couple years so you can go watch that if
you want to get a little more frame
around that but
um
yeah so i was thinking about doing this
video for a while now and there's a
tweet that elon musk put out the other
day actually
yeah here i'll show you that first
um so elon has this fsd beta coming out
which stands for full self driving for
tesla cars
um
i guess that's the code for it it rolls
out friday midnight to a thousand so to
approximately a thousand owners with a
perfect 100 out of 100 safety scores on
their driving
now this doesn't make a lot of sense to
me
because
if it's
fully automatic driving why does your
driving skills have anything to do with
what the automatic or the autopilot is
going to do if the autopilot has the
capacity to drive
better than humans which it arguably
should
um any faults you have in your driving
shouldn't matter but they're only giving
the rollout to people that have perfect
safety scores
as the tesla car tracks it
as you're driving it it says there uh
rollouts will hold for several days and
after that see how it goes
uh if that looks good beta will
gradually begin rolling out to the 99
scores and below
now some of you might think well it
doesn't really matter that's
insignificant blah blah blah blah but
um last week i don't know if you guys
you guys already know i'm a car guy
as per the title of the channel
um so i'm not watching crap on youtube
about how to get the girls
um i already know that um my
my youtube viewing probably consists
mostly of stuff around cars and sailing
and
a few other uh you know like be better
sort of uh notions and this guy brock
has this youtube channel called drag
times
uh good dude i'd probably like to get
him on at some point for a plane to win
episode
but over here i watch this video that
says will tells us say i'm a bad driver
will i get the full and what does it say
after that uh full self driving i paid
ten thousand dollars for so he paid ten
thousand dollars for an option which he
can't get
so follow me on this okay this is the
logic of what this whole social credit
system is going to look like you pay 10
grand as an option
for something he can't get i'm not going
to play the video you guys can go watch
it if you want it's on his channel
uh but the end result of it was he got a
5 out of 100 score driving the car as
you can see by the cover photo he's got
quite a few fast cars and by the time by
the name of the channel it he does a lot
of drag racing on it
you know just check out the quarter mile
speeds and uh you know half miles and 0
60s and stuff like that but he could not
he's he's definitely not going to get
the beta roll out of this full
self-driving from tesla because he won't
qualify because of his driving
it takes factors into consideration like
uh acceleration cornering speed
follow distance and a bunch of other
stuff i'm
again if you guys want to know what all
the details are you can go look that up
but it it basically takes into
consideration how you drive right now
and then it says okay well if you're a
hundred at 100 score then we're gonna
give you the software update that you
paid for if you're not then you don't
get the software update until we feel
like giving it to you
so that's how things are starting to
roll out huh you're paying for that
you cannot get or take advantage of
so i watched this other video that
followed up after it over here and it
says it's okay to speed and run red
light so it doesn't take into account
your speed versus the speed limit it
doesn't take into account if you go
through a red light um
but he says but turns and breaking are
the problem so
it it tracks your
you know i'm assuming there's some sort
of accelerometer in the car uh that
tracks your g-forces and if you're going
around a corner i think you said more
than .4 g's then you're not a good
driver and it's going to lower your
score
cars like this i mean most cars like my
mclaren will probably pull like
1.05 maybe 1.1 gs you know depending on
the tires i have in the car and the
surface but they can pull a lot of g's
very like they're glued to the road
especially if you have arrow and all
that sort of stuff
so
they've decided unilaterally pay for
this software update but we're only
going to give it to you if your driving
is good even though you're driving
should have no relevance whatsoever on
full self driving because the car
technically should be able to drive
itself you've seen how this is starting
to roll out right you know you're paying
for stuff that you're not getting access
to they're they're only giving you
access
if you have a certain score now some of
my haters and critics might say
something along the lines well good
because we don't want people driving
fast and
stuff like that and blah blah blah blah
well let me introduce a few more
things for you guys to consider
uh
try to make these a little bit bigger so
you can see them
so i don't know who this guy is but i
had this tweet forwarded to me uh the
other day he says the year is 2031. so
10 years from now
your electric car locked you out because
you reached your driving limit
okay that that's something that might
show up on a social credit score
tracking you know mechanism maybe you've
got a limit of a certain number of
kilometers or miles you can drive every
single month you've reached that limit
you can now no longer use that car
you walk to a store to buy your food the
steak you want to buy gets denied
because you've reached your co2 limit
you walk home with a bag of bugs and
fake soy meat
and the vegans right now are laughing
going
that's good so let's roll out social
credit wrong
what happens if social credit
encompasses everything which it will
it's not just going to be you know car
guys or people that like meat or
anything like that that's you know
tied into that side of the equation
let's go to the other side of the
equation let's go to the soy guys let's
go to the vegans and let's uh
because we're all in this together guys
this is not an us versus them thing when
it comes to society this is an us
meaning society itself versus the state
thing
where the us the state is them okay
you go to the grocery store and you want
to buy
i don't know your soy latte mix beverage
whatever the hell it is um or you want
to buy your soylent drinks or whatever
it is that you're drinking or your bag
of veggies or whatever let's say that
you're buying certain things that
would affect your co2 limit
we know that they mostly grow soy in the
amazon rainforest where they're like
basically clearing trees out
that's where most of the soy comes from
so what happens if you reach your limit
with that what happens if it's a
far left wing i've got a few notes here
what happens if it's a far left wing
socialist that wants unlimited free
abortions what happens if you reach your
limit with that
just saying you know what happens if
they're tracking that and they say nope
sorry
nothing for you this month because
you've already had your limits in the
last six months or something like that
right
just something to consider uh there's an
interesting video which again i'm not
going to play uh it's called i'm just
going to add it to the stream and put it
up here
and kind of play it back at a super fast
speed and do a little bit of voice over
for you so you can get an idea of what
we're looking at
there's two times
um so this is on a channel called your
new social or sorry it's called it's by
tom scott and it says your new social
credit score
it's buffering now for some reason i
hope that's not a problem with my
internet anyway i'm going to pause it
because it seems to be a problem playing
but go watch it it says your new social
credit score and some people thought
this was real
some people actually you know started
throwing us around the internet saying
oh this is what's coming you know this
is this is already out there this is
what they're doing but they're not this
is a spoof okay the publisher of this
particular video pinned a top comment
down on me here uh where is it
update on the 13th of april 2021 i've
been told that some conspiracy theorists
are bizarrely calculating this video as
fact to be clear this is a speculative
fiction from 2018 part of a sci-fi
series on the channel blah blah blah so
this is a complete spoof it is it is
completely you know
it is not non-fiction it is fiction and
people are tossing around like it's
already happening right now but the way
they break it down the way it's been
broken down you're going to see exactly
what i'm talking about when you go watch
that right
um yeah kong says can't wait till they
ask for your bench press max before
buying your groceries conch what if they
say what if you got to stand on a scale
before you buy your groceries right and
they limit what it is that you can buy
because your body mass index is not to
their liking
and you're not allowed to buy certain
things anymore that might affect your
health or your weight i don't have any
problem with that but there might be
some people that have certain food
addictions um that might have a problem
with that right um the you know this
question again it's not about a left
versus right or us versus them in
society going down the social credit
score route which is already happening
but as i pointed out with what tesla's
doing is one example there's thousands
more i'm going to show you a couple more
um it's going to create basically four
classes of people
elites
the sheep the broken sheep and the black
market okay um you have a you have a
good score you've got the money to pay
for uh exemptions maybe you're going to
be in the elite category that's not me
that's not you that's not anybody with
probably
less than 100 million dollars in net
worth you're going to have to have some
serious bank to be in that category
the sheep are all going to be the ones
that quietly comply um they will follow
everything to the rule they're the ones
that ran right out as soon as the
government said hey we have an
experimental vaccine that hasn't been uh
put through any kind of clinical trials
on a long-term basis come and take the
job and save your life they're like
let's run out
those guys
the sheep there's going to be a lot of
sheep and there's going to be broken
sheep who are going to have a low score
maybe because
i don't know they shoplifted maybe
because they were speeding in their car
maybe because they exceeded their limit
of car co2 emissions for the month and
they are no longer allowed to buy
certain things or have access to certain
things or maybe leave their house what
happens if you can't leave your house
because there's a smart lock on your
house because the government has you and
you know these giant towers these glass
boxes they call condominiums sometimes
they're also called uh you know housing
they're all the same thing what happens
if they put smart locks on those and you
can't leave your house
right because you've been a bad boy or a
bad girl maybe you were protesting you
know somebody or something or a
president or a corporation and you know
god forbid you're not allowed to go out
anymore you can't leave your house a
smart lock won't let you go out until
your score goes higher until you've done
certain things or certain tasks or wait
a certain period of time because your
timeout's over right
what if you go to the store and you were
you know one of these far lefties that
likes dying their hair purple green or
you know
uh
all those nasty colors um and you can't
buy your hair dye because you've
exceeded your limit because it does
environmental damage right what if right
okay it's not just left versus right
center uh liberal versus conservative
versus libertarian this is an us versus
them thing meaning it's us versus us as
in society versus the state imposing
limiting
limiting uh things on us what if your
voting privileges get revoked
right you can't vote
entirely possible
all of a sudden that see
see what you guys continue to overlook
that i've been banging on for years now
okay you want personal freedom you don't
want giant ass government telling you
what to do you want personal freedom the
problem is though is that the government
baits people
and the sheep aren't bright enough to
see the code in the matrix to see what's
going on i am i've been looking at the
code in the matrix for years now
most people just say oh yeah they you
know they love and care for us i've
lobbied with the government
10 12 years ago on a bill
that was going to make getting out of
debt more expensive limit consumer
options ruin their credit more
and
take longer to improve your credit okay
there was four critical components of
the bill that i was talking to the
provincial government in ontario at
queen's park on dealt with the critics
jack nick sim was one of the critics
here in ontario that guy's a lying pos
lied right to my face
and
they don't care about what's good for
the consumer i've watched them firsthand
i've seen the code in the matrix they
only care about themselves and retaining
their authority and control so as long
as you keep voting for big government
thinking that free is good
let's tax the rich you know that popular
face
hey you know you guys want to keep
voting for that that's what you're going
to get you're going to get more of the
social credit system
what if you get limits to access to
medicine if you have a low score right
what if you're one of the guys out there
and i'm not pro vax or anti-vax i'm pro
make a decision for yourself that works
right i mean there's certain people that
should probably get in certain people
which it just doesn't make a lot of
sense but let's say that you don't take
the jabs that they want you to that year
the boosters that they want you to that
year because you've made a unilateral
choice in your own interest to do what's
better for you and then you need medical
assistance for something totally
unrelated you know to any kind of
outcome or disease that might come out
of it but you don't get the medical
treatment that you're looking for right
that's what happens with state runs
health care
that's what happens with social credit
systems
you guys are gonna now i'm a big fan of
blockchain money
huge fan i've been talking about it for
a while cryptocurrency is going to
change the world the blockchain is going
to change the world but the government
is already realizing that they're going
to have to issue stead state issued
currency i don't know what they're going
to call it the fed coin
the you know the fed usd coin the
canadian fed coin or whatever it's going
to be called
because it's on the blockchain and you
can use smart contracts with it if you
use their currency they're going to know
exactly what you're using the money for
it's not like you know you can take cash
out of your atm and you can buy whatever
you want with them they have no idea
what you're doing with it
if you're going to be using a blockchain
based currency which is going to come
right if if people don't adopt things
like
bitcoin monero you know maybe some of
the other privacy coins some of the
other d5 projects that come out stuff
like that
if the masses if the sheep just go okay
big government
and just shift over and abandon a
currency system
that gives them at least some amount of
privacy and autonomy
and
is permissionless
and is censorship resistant if they if
they go right onto the government system
you know what's going to happen they're
going to know exactly what you buy all
the time
you buy
too much meat you buy too much soy you
buy too much of something that's going
to
rack up a score that's going to throw
off your social credit score you're
banned from it uh it you know buying
certain things might limit your score
maybe if you buy too much alcohol or too
much cigarettes or too much weed or too
much
too many condoms too many plan b's you
know any any one of things could lower
your score right
just think about it you know it's coming
it's already here it's not even like
it's coming it's already here like hi
cold hard truth bombs bomber command
welcome to rich cooper's bomber command
this is it guys this is this is what is
going down
you